The world's
longest scientific
study of happiness
is now in its 85th year.
Researchers at Harvard have been studying
a pool of subjects
and their descendants since 1938.
The objective
to unlock the age
old question of what makes a good life.
Originally there were 724 participants.
268 were sophomores at Harvard.
Their ranks included
future President
John F Kennedy and future
Washington Post editor Ben Bradlee.
The study later
incorporated a parallel one
that was tracking
456 less privileged inner city
Boston boys.
Thereafter, the pool was expanded
to include 1300 descendants.
They've been tracking these folks
for 84 years
and the retention rate
for the original participants
an amazing 84%.
Every two years
the participants
and answer
lengthy questionnaires every five years
they surrender their medical records.
Every 15 years
they are interviewed face to face.
So what's the life lesson
Good relationships keep us happier,
healthier and help us live longer.
There's a new book about the study.
It's called The Good Life
Lessons from the World's
Longest Scientific Study of Happiness.
The authors are Mark Schultz,
a clinical psychologist,
associate director of the study.
And my next guest, Robert Waldinger,
a Harvard
psychiatrist and director
of the Harvard Study
of Adult Development.
Dr.
Waldinger,
thank you so much for being here.
Physical fitness, we all know about that.
That's important
but so often
overlooked is what you regard
as social fitness. What is that
It's the finding in our research
that people who do the best,
who are happiest and healthiest,
maintain their relationships.
They're active
in keeping up their relationships,
keeping contact with friends
and family and community members.
You say that the folks who get 50
are solid in their relationships
are going to be the ones at age 80
who are both physically and mentally.
Most South Is it too late?
I mean, for
some people watching right now
who may be older.
Is it too late
to follow your prescription?
It is never too late.
Our study shows us that
people find friends.
They find love
when they're sure it's
never going to happen for them at all.
Different points of their lives
And a lot depends on
whether you are intentional
about making and nurturing
good relationships.
Your original pool,
both both sides of the study are
white men.
How reliable
are your findings
for people who are not white men?
Well, now we have gender balance.
So we brought in spouses.
We brought in children,
more than half of whom are women.
So we have gender balance.
And what we do is
we make sure that our findings
are replicated
by other studies
of nonwhite people
and by people all over the world.
So we're we are confident
that these findings are true
for people of all backgrounds.
I had you on my radio program
and callers,
after you left, pointed out my deficiency
in not asking about pets
and not asking about religion.
Address both of those now
We did not study
pets, but there are studies
that tell us that
the touch of a pet petting a pet
actually lowers
heart rate,
calms us down,
has a health benefit in that way
with religion.
What we found was that religious people
weren't
happier than non-religious people
and they weren't less happy.
But our religious people
and people who had spiritual practices
said that they found these practices
a real comfort in times of stress.
There's a lot of data out there.
Gene Twangy
comes to mind about the relationship.
I'm not sure if she would say causation,
but she would definitely say correlation
between problems of mental
health, anxiety, depression
among young Americans,
and their connectivity
So how does social media factor
into this?
Because I'm worried
that too many young people
are behind closed doors.
Not having
the type of interactions
that you say are so important.
And it's a big worry right now
in our culture.
What the research is starting to show us
is that it
depends on how we use social media.
If we actively use social media
to connect with other people,
that's likely to increase
our happiness levels.
If we passively consume
somebody else's Instagram feeds
somebody else's happy pictures of beaches
and parties,
that's going to lower our self-esteem.
That's going to make us feel like
we're missing out on the good life,
which isn't the truth.
You know, time and again in the book,
you would present parallel tracks,
short bios of some of the folks
who are in this control group,
if that's the right way to say it.
The person
you might expect to end up
with the happiest life,
it's often not the case
Yeah.
We found, for example,
we had two people who started out
as Harvard
undergraduates, lives of privilege,
all set up to have great lives.
One was our happiest man
who had a very ordinary career
as a wonderful high school teacher,
but nothing fancy.
And another, a very prominent attorney
who worked hard all his life
and won lots of awards.
And he was one of our least happy people.
And the difference
between them
was the extent
to which they paid attention
to and took care of the connections
they had with family, friends, community
Dr.
Waldinger, before you leave me,
give us something
everyone watching can do today
in line with the findings of your book,
The Good Life.
Yeah, Take small actions.
It doesn't have to be big.
Think of somebody
you miss,
somebody you'd like to connect with.
Just send them a text.
Send them an email saying, Hi,
I was thinking of you
and just wanted to connect.
And if you do that regularly
with the people in your life
who you value,
you'll be amazed at the positive
emotion and the positive connection
that comes back to you.